[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous lundi 8 janvier une
nouvelle semaine d'information locale
sur tv à 60,18 bienvenue dans cette
édition
tout de suite les titres de ce set 8
journal l'hommage ce matin à carrières
sous poissy à clarisse à jean-philippe
la policière qui était domicilié dans la
commune avait été tué à montrouge lors
des attentats de 2015 une centaine de
personnes a participé à la cérémonie qui
s'est tenue devant le square de la ville
qui porte son nom reprendre ses études à
n'importe quel âge le conservatoire
national des arts et métiers d'île de
france ouvre ses inscriptions pour le
second semestre
il propose des formations et des des
formations diplômantes et certifiant
pour améliorer ses compétences pour en
parler sophie à bérard directrice du
cnam ile-de-france et mari de dengue
gestionnaire du centre de versailles et
puis un vent de renouveau sur saint
quentin à gospel le jeune simon le héros
est désormais le chef de choeur
remplaçant à l'historique eric barbier
il est notre invité en compagnie de
michel renard chargée de communication
pour la chorale c'était il ya trois
jours il ya trois ans jour pour jour le
8 janvier 2015 carissa jean-philippe
policière municipale de montrouge
étaient assassinés dans l'exercice de
ses fonctions
elle habitait carrières sous poissy
depuis 2011 la ville lui a rendu un
hommage ce matin en présence de sa
famille des habitants et des écoliers
qui ont interprété des chants d'espoir
une cérémonie devant le square qui porte
désormais son nom situé juste à côté de
là où elle habitait propos recueillis
par camille lambert et c'est pour ça
qu'on a voulu que ce square ici soient
réalisés là où elle courait et puisqu'on
est vraiment sur les lieux de vie de
clarisse à un tous les jours ou
plusieurs fois par semaine et korian sur
ses berges de seine donc c'est vraiment
ces lieux de vie ces lieux où elle est
épanouie elle était joyeuse et ses
essais ça cette rupture qui se fait
quand il ya un assassinat quand il ya
une mort c'est cette rupture de cette
joie de vivre de cet épanouissement qui
est tout à coup s'arrête qui met un
terme à tout cet investissement qui a
été le sien auprès de la république au
clair des autres prêts de la sécurité et
ça je crois qu'il faut pas l'oublier et
c'est ça qu'on veut entretenir de sa
mémoire à elle
une deuxième cérémonie d'hommage s'est
tenue à montrouge cet après midi en
présence du ministre de l'intérieur
gérard collomb un livre enquête sur
trappe qui vient de sortir aux éditions
albin michel les deux à grand reporter
raphaëlle bacqué ariane chemin signe à
la communauté plongez au coeur de la
ville de la banlieue ouest de paris pour
mieux la comprendre bonsoir moussa fall
harbaoui bonson vous êtes l'ancien
président de l'étoile sportive de
trappes le club de football de la ville
est également au président de
l'association pharma citoyens alors le
chapitre 21 de ce livre vous est
consacré une dizaine de pages intitulé
two sobrement président larbaoui un mot
d'abord sur la démarche
qu'en pensez vous les deux auteurs
parlent de trappes commune vi inouïe une
ville romanesque je cite c'est une
communauté attachante comme une famille
redoutable comme redoutable comme un
clan pardon est il normal de lui
consacrer un vilain un livre sur 7 sur
cette ville de trappes
je pense je pense qu'on peut y consacrer
un livre la preuve c'est qu'ils l'ont
fait ensuite il ya bien sûr beaucoup de
choses à dire sur ce sursaut livre on y
reviendra dans la soirée le mans dans le
détail mais deux journalistes
d'investigation qui travaille au monde
qu'ont l'habitude de mener des enquêtes
approfondies elles ont fait des livres
sur d'autres d'autres sujets souvent
souvent des sujets assez assez majeur
est assez lourd
concernant la ville de trappes voilà on
pourrait éventuellement parler à la fois
du titre de la méthode et la façon de
teint sans arriver à ce livre
moi j'ai été contacté jouer je m'excuse
lancé avant
pardonne et et ses lecteurs et
spectateurs preuve que c'est en direct
c'est vrai que la démarche était
intéressante en ce sens où elles ont
décidé de mener une enquête sur le long
terme
on a souvent critiqué les journalistes
pour dire qu'ils venaient faire un one
shot venez un coup prenez des infos
souvent relayée finalement quand il y
avait une actualité 20e une actualité
brûlante
souvent quand il ya une actualité qui
pouvaient défrayé la chronique comme on
dit là en l'occurrence ne peut pas leur
reprocher elles sont venues à des
moments on va dire c'est pas forcément
des temps forts et dans la durée
ça c'est le premier point ensuite le
second point on pourrait imaginer qu'il
ya une démarche quand même marketing
très intelligente parce que c'est une
succession de portraits enchevêtrés dans
la chronologie est là bien évidemment
voilà ça laisse à ça laisserait à penser
que tu rappes finalement serait une
espèce de comment dire de deux
pouponnières de deux talents talent est
une espèce de ville de sa serait
quasiment une boîte de prod puisqu'on y
à intégrer des gens comme jamel debbouze
omar sy anelka et il ya ce cet angle qui
a été choisi d'aller chercher des
personnalités et autour de ces
personnalités plaquer tous les éléments
on va dire de ce que la société dans son
ensemble peut vivre
donc on va y plaquer dessus le
fondamentalisme envers plaquer je le dis
parce que c'est un petit poème un petit
peu beaucoup notamment sur le sujet
record douala n'ont jamais voté pour
l'évacuer finalement qui sont partis en
syrie et par les durs est c'est à dire
que oui on peut parler de l'immigration
alors elle en parle à chaque fin c'est
l'intérêt ce qui est intéressant c'est
la manière dont elles l'ont traité c'est
à dire ce sont des portraits mais de
gens connus qui dit connu dit finalement
avant on a envie d'en savoir plus les
concernant donc ça fait un gros public
ce n'est pas une démarche et
stigmatisantes cette fois ci quand on
peut le voir dans souvent dans les
reportages vous l'avez dit sur des
actualités moulin entre parents c'est
pas stigmatisant il ya des vérités
il ya des approximations j'en ai même
fait l'objet non dans mon passage sept
approximatif
à mon sens me concernant je leur ai même
écrit pour leur dit
mais c'est pas stigmatiser pourquoi par
exemple sur le passage on y reviendra
peut-être alain mais comment dire non
stigmatisant il ya des choses
intéressantes par exemple la chute du
communisme on veut plaqué la chute d'un
comment dire d'un parti avec toute une
littérature structurantes qui serait
remplacé après la mire du mur après la
chute du mur de berlin par l'islam
sachant qu'on voit cela pratiquement à
l'échelle internationale c'est
reconnaître des idéologies qui tombe
d'autres qui prennent le relais
donc elles sont toutes ses vagues c'est
à dire les migrations le chômage la
montée des idéologies de toutes sortes
et en même temps leur démarche naturelle
elle est venue parce que ben voilà il ya
omar sy jamel debbouze lesbien et en
même temps ça finit par un titre qui moi
me pour le coup mais j'aime puisque ça
finit par la communauté comme citrap
était une communauté elle le dit elle
même c'est pas une thèse ami noté comme
une famille comme un clan ouais comme
comme une famille comme un clan donc
elle même le dit avant de venir on était
par définition on avait des a priori
parce qu'elles disent nous étions
surpris de l'accueil que nous avons reçu
voilà donc déjà le fait d'être surprise
avant pour bien qu'on a tous des a
priori c'est a priori et ses préjugés
sont tombés admirablement bien accueilli
tout le monde a parlé comme on dit parce
qu'il ya la loi du silence
on entend des choses comme ça sur la
commune bah voilà tout le monde a parlé
librement
quand on parle de pression par exemple
sur dans la thèse du livre ça serait une
espèce de pression par rapport à la
communauté religieuse mais on parle pas
de respect il ya des gens qui vont pas
en affrontements mais pas parce qu'ils
sont d'accord ou pas d'accord mais parce
qu'il ya un respect aussi des uns et des
autres et que c'est pas une
la communauté mais bien une mosaïque de
gens qui vivent très bien ensemble et
une plongée souvent dit la plupart des
habitants mériterait le prix nobel de la
paix pour y vivre en paix et en même
temps il ya des problèmes à gérer
nous répétons lieu minutes mustapha
larbaoui juste sur le passage en phase
concerne y revient sur votre passage
finalement aussi à l'étoile sportive de
cap de 2003 jusqu'à 2017
des approximations on roule vite une
approximation
essentiellement une parce qu on a
quasiment fait l'affiché électorale
mike tyson et holyfield sert les deux
poids lourds
puisqu'il est question d'un match final
ali rabais mustapha la révélation aux
élections il se projette dans l'avenir
de mise à une municipale ce que c'est
une affabulation alors j'irai pas jusque
là parce que les questions ont été
posées certains m'ont dit vous revenez
souvent sur trappe c'est pour ça
qu'elles ont consacré un passager j'aime
m'y attendais pas mais votre nom revient
souvent au quelqu'un on vous verrez bien
on se projette très moi j'ai toujours
dit que la vie publique m'intéresse
l'associatif en particulier bien sûr je
réfléchirai vie politique et donc en
haletant dans deux ans et puis j'espère
que tous les citoyens de trappes et et
de toutes les cités de france et toutes
les communes de france pense que dans
leur rôle de citoyen on peut également
briguer des mandats c'est pas simplement
se départit donc oui j'y pense oui je
travaille j'ai passé surtout pas pris ma
décision
donc la fiche est un peu prémédité merci
il va falloir d'abord être avec eux je
rappelle un chapitre vous est consacré
dans ce livre la communauté et je
précise qu'on recevra les deux auteurs
de ce livre ça sera mercredi dans le
journal merci d'avancé mais avec tout du
nouveau pour le réseau des bus à saint
quentin en yvelines depuis aujourd'hui
l'offre est considérablement renforcé la
ligne 50 râler minul et l'agglomération
voit sa fréquence remodeler un passage
toutes les 30 minutes en heure de pointe
contre 45 auparavant elles de 14 à 60 9
courses par jour pour la ligne 51 et une
plus grosse amplitude horaire elle relie
à saint quentin en yvelines à l'hôpital
mignot au chesnay
enfin la ligne 15 entre elles en cours
et à saint-cloud fait également l'objet
d'un renfort important
douze nouvelles courses en heures
creuses et quatre en heure de pointe
en sport il faisait à la une de l'équipe
ce week-end le plus petit poucet de la
coupe de france de football où il n'a
pas réussi l'exploit en 32e de finale
samedi
élimination à domicile face à concarneau
sur le score de 3 buts à 0 devant 2000
spectateurs
cinq divisions séparaient les deux clubs
le récit de la rencontre nicolas landry
est nickel et me d'euros
et soyez solidarité aventure et c'est
normal concentration maximale pour les
joueurs d'où il ya quelques minutes
d'entrer sur leur terrain pour affronter
concarneau en 32e de finale de la coupe
de france cinq divisions séparent le
petit poucet de l'équipe bretonne
pensionnaire de nationale une
une fois sur le terrain concarneau
marque deux buts dans les 15 premières
minutes dans une ambiance électrique 2 0
ce sera le score à la mi temps c'est
très compliqué on a fait une entame de
match très compliquée j'ai senti tendu
pas comme d'habitude mais ça fait partie
du sport maintenant moi personnellement
on va essayer de revenir à dos on va
voir comment ils vont réagir
concarneau la rapprocher une entame de
match compliquée qui ne décourage pas
les 2000 supporters présents au stade
pour le premier 32e de finale du club
depuis 1940 un mois de ça joue 90
minutes donc temps que le coup de
sifflet final il est bas il n'est pas de
cycle et on peut toujours y croire après
je pense que faut être réaliste un petit
peu et je pense que concarneau à jouer
tranquillement va bien sûr j'y crois
encore c'est là que je suis devenu
microbes bien sûr je rentrais chez moi
au retour des vestiaires pas de miracle
ou ne reviendra pas concarneau marque
même un troisième but par
l'intermédiaire dit daz à la 84e minute
pour mettre fin à l'épopée des yvelinois
ce qu'en finale 3 0
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
déçue déçue de déçus de la philosophie
du match parce qu'en première mi temps
je pense qu'on les a trop respectés et
après en deuxième on a été plus haut on
a montré qu'on avait un peu de qualité
mais bon c'est le football c'est comme
ça après cette parenthèse coupe de
france où devra replonger rapidement
dans le quotidien du championnat de r3
où il occupe la dernière place
prochain match le dimanche 14 janvier
sur le terrain de choisy le roi tandis
que jean-paul goude voyettes reprendre
ses études avant ou même 65 ans c'est
possible à partir du 5 mars 2018 le
conservatoire national des arts et
métiers d'île de france fait sa rentrée
du second semestre pour les adultes
le cnam propose des formations
certifiantes et diplômantes avec moi en
plateau de invité sophie bérard bonsoir
bonsoir est la directrice du clam
ile-de-france et bonsoir marie d'un
acquittement ça vous est la gestionnaire
du centre d'enseignement du cnam à
versailles alors deux semestre au cnam
finalement c'est un peu comme à
l'université
oui on peut dire ça effectivement on est
calée sur les années universitaires
on démarre en octobre on va bientôt
faire les examens de février pour ceux
qui ont commencé en octobre et donc on
va commencer notre deuxième rentrée on
recommence juste après les vacances de
février donc début mars avec des examens
en juillet alors pour présenter un petit
peu le cnam
il est placé sous la tutelle du ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur oui le cnam
et un grand établissement d'enseignement
supérieur qui a plus de deux cent vingt
ans et la spécialité où notre spécialité
c'est la formation professionnelle pour
adultes donc reprendre ses études
valider des nouvelles compétences et
obtenir des diplômes tout au long de sa
vie ça c'est possible on l'a dit 20 à 65
ans même les acteurs après exactement
tout au long de sa vie tant qu'on
travaille puisque pour valider un
diplôme au cnam il faut avoir de
l'expérience professionnelle d'accord
c'est des formations très pratique et
très intéressante pour les employeurs
puisque on a des compétences directement
employables alors marie denain qu'on la
dit formation certifiante diplômante qui
peut permettre voilà de deux d'améliorer
ses compétences peut-être et vendre
envisager un changement de métier à une
évolution de carrière
on se dit aussi c'est important pour les
estime de soi vous qui êtes aux
gestionnaires au sein de versailles
c'est aussi pour ça que les les
personnes ont envie de reprendre les
adultes ont envie de reprendre leurs
études
on a tous types de profils qui ceux qui
viennent vers nous au cnam pour des
formations c'est des gens qui vont être
en reconversion professionnelle des gens
qui sont en manque de qualification et
donc qui cherchent à avoir un diplôme ou
un certificat et puis après tout
simplement des gens qui veulent se
perfectionner sur des domaines qui
parfois n'ont pas forcément de rapport
avec leur métier actuel alors le cnam en
ile de france c'est combien de centres
d'enseignement neuf centres
d'enseignement réparties sur toute l'île
de france
avec 6000 personnes qui se forme chaque
année plus d apprentis plus des gens en
entreprise pour lequel on fait aussi des
formations certifiantes et diplômantes
mais là spécifique par rapport à un
cahier des charges des entreprises
serait donc toujours professionnel sur
le centre de versailles on a à peu près
combien de personnes travaillent c'est
500 auditeurs sur l'année sans compter
les apprentis l'apprenti en est
à peu près 150 apprentis et du coup est
ce que c'est la même offre qui est
dispensée sur tous les centres
d'enseignement de versailles on va
trouver des choses différentes par
centre oui c'est pas la même chose
puisqu'en fait on cherche à s'adapter
aux besoins des bassins ce qu'on n'a pas
dit c'est que les formations ont lieu en
cours en cours du soir soit une 18h30 à
21h30 salle à manger l'emploi du temps à
la vie sa maison et donc les gens rendre
d'abord chez eux ils viennent en
formation chez nous et donc
à versailles je laisserais par des maris
mais on les forme technique et on a par
exemple à poissy qui est pas très loin
on a des formations en ressources
humaines
c'est ca 2,5 fois ci versailles
ils montrent aussi d'accord et du coup
sûr le centre de versailles qu'est-ce
qu'on quel type de formation peut-on se
lèvera sur le centre de versailles si
les diplômes d'ingénieur en spécialité
informatique électronique et après tout
type de formation d'enfants psychologie
en comptabilité en psycho enfin
psychologie ressources humaines très
variés tous accessibles à partir du
niveau bac ou on peut y accéder a enfin
comment ça se passe contre elle un
niveau bac on va être sur des
certificats voit juste sur de la
compétence est par contre après plutôt
sur du bac + 3 sur tout ce qui est
licence sur ressources humaines
psychologie et après des titre rncp
niveau ii bac + 4 et après l'ingénieur
des questions plus pratiques pour
terminer on l'a dit les les cours se
déroulent le samedi matin le soir voilà
donc tous les soirs de la semaine 18h30
21h 30
donc là pour le centre de versailles
c'est dans le lycée jules ferry donc
voilà un parking à côté donc c'est assez
pratique pour se garer donc la priorité
c'est d'abord d'aller rencontrer
l'équipe de versailles pour définir son
projet professionnel définir quel cursus
on veut suivre puis ensuite en fonction
de ses disponibilités ont via un soir de
soir3 soir on peut aussi faire de la
formation ouverte à distance d'accord
pour éviter d'utiliser trottoirs ou le
samedi matin
et puis l'idée c'est de valider un
diplôme et puis ensuite on fait des
remises de diplômes tous les ans ou tous
les deux ans pour récompenser tous les
auditeurs qui ont bien fonctionné
dernière chose les droits d'inscription
qui s'élèvent à combien pour une année
par exemple lors une année c'est un 60
euros de droit d'inscription et ensuite
les courses entre 56 et 168 euros
merci beaucoup à tout les deux maris de
zinc à ma droite et à sophie bérard
d'avoir été avec nous pour plus
d'informations sur les inscriptions les
horaires d'ouverture aussi du centre de
versailles les autres centres en ile de
france vous pouvez vous rendre sur le
site internet du ctam ile-de-france qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci à vous
deux
ce sont des planchettes en bois qui vous
évoque forcément quelque chose les caps
là sont en exposition à l'espace richaud
de versailles à voir sur place les
répliques des plus grands monuments
européens en cap là c'est un événement
victime de son succès puisque
l'exposition est prolongée jusqu'au 14
janvier reportage de mélanie poker et
nicolas dans louis si vous l'avez vous
fait un plan incliné
évidemment là elle va tomber mais si
vous l'orienter doucement dans le sens
de la pente
elle va tenir à condition bien sûr que
la pente ne soit pas trop fort et voilà
le secret de la tour de pise
l'un des milieux européens de
l'exposition archi capela pour matériaux
les célèbres capela en trente ans près
de 80 millions de planchette ont été
vendus
j'ai déjà fait un peu on pourrait
marcher dessus parce que moi j'ai déjà
c'est donc sans retour
j'ai fait une tour qui monte jusqu'au
plafond et les caps là ils adorent donc
c'est très chouette de pouvoir leur
montrer des très belles réalisations
ça leur permet de donner des idées
pourquoi refaire des choses à la maison
version miniature pas de colle mais
environ 60000 planche est utilisé à la
réalisation des enfants versailles et du
ce2 au cm2 il faut une dextérité
manuelle tout de même fine fine parce
que les équilibres sont complexes
même les maisons vous regarderez au
centre du delà de la chapelle il y a
d'la d'une petite maison
mais même pour faire les fenêtres c'est
déjà on se met sur est une demie
épaisseur de kapla voyez parfois la
planche
donc c'est déjà delà de la manipulation
fils l'exposition est un vrai succès
depuis son ouverture le 23 décembre
dernier la file d'attenté en témoigne
1200 visiteurs en moyenne voyagent
chaque jour ce week end vous avez
sûrement à manger de la galette des rois
entre amis ou en famille la galette des
rois c'est le rendez vous incontournable
du début d'année
c'est aussi une affaire de spécialiste
depuis quelques années un concours
organisé pour récompenser à la meilleure
galette des yvelines est organisée
et cette année elle se trouve à
noisy-le-roi découverte avec michael et
demi d'euros patrick jacques de dixmude
et nicolas kirillovitch la meilleure
galette des rois se prépare à noisy le
roi c'est ici précisément que l'on garde
le secret de fabrication et dont profite
ses clients une bonne galette vaut bien
quelques minutes d'attentes salle une
habitude cette violence débrouille oui
pour moi mais c'est tous les jours ne
vont pas sans que lundi quand il est
fermé mais chez lui tous ces gâteaux à
je suis content je content pour lui
et puis pour nous parce qu'il ya plus de
monde encore lancé il ya quatre ans par
le syndicat des artisans boulangers
pâtissiers des yvelines près d'une
soixantaine de professionnels ont pris
part cette année au concours pour se
démarquer de la concurrence tout est
dans la recette de la farine du beurre
et de la poudre d'amandes savoir faire
un tour de main
on a en a mis les matières premières qui
[Musique]
qui ont été sélectionnés par un parent
aimant employés moi même on a travaillé
ensemble dessus donc c'était vraiment un
très beau produit trois jours offert le
faîtage laisser reposer donné les tours
et après laffaire la veille qu'elle
repose encore et l'action de même
l'épiphanie passé les caprices du roy
proposeront des galettes jusqu'en
février comptait 32 euros pour un
produit entier est 600 pièces ont été
vendues en l'espace d'un week end et du
nouveau pour la chorale saint quentin
gospel avec moi à deux invités en
plateau pour en parler michel renard
bonsoir serge est chargée de
communication pour saint-quentin gospel
et bonsoir à simon le héros bonsoir à 24
ans vous êtes désormais le chef de
choeur de cette chorale saint quentinois
que vous avez remplacé à l'historique
eric barbier fondateur de saint-quentin
gospel en 94 premières questions pas
trop d'appréhension a succédé à éric
barbier et surtout pourquoi avoir eu
envie de rejoindre saint quentin gospel
alors pas trop d'appréhension si
quelques quelques appréhensions ne
serait ce que parce que c'est un gros
groupe
bien sûr est que et que la direction
d'un gros groupe c'est évidemment
beaucoup de gestion des ressources
humaines aussi est évidemment à 24 ans
j'ai pas forcément beaucoup d'expérience
là dedans
même si j'ai eu l'occasion de diriger un
choeur précédemment qui était un petit
peu plus gros aussi avec un orchestre
symphonique plus dans la musique
classique des appréhensions aussi parce
qu'effectivement c'est un chef
historique qui était là depuis 25 ans
moi j'en ai 24 bien ça la chorale est
finalement presque aussi vieille que
plus âgés mais mais effectivement j'ai
24 ans j'ai même s'il 24 ans la chorale
on a 25 et donc du coup c'est vrai que
les appréhensions sont là par rapport au
fait de succéder à quelqu'un qui était
là depuis longtemps avec ses habitudes
de direction avec ses habitudes de
gestion et donc le fait de passer
derrière mais un petit challenge entre
guillemets sur le
sur le fait à la fois d'être de garder
ce qui fonctionne dans un coeur est
aussi d'amener une petite touche de
nouveauté dans ce cadre là c'est un vent
de jeunesse michel qui souffre
finalement sur sur la chorale avec
l'arrivée de de simon et est ce que
c'était voilà un quelque chose
d'important d'avoir ce vent de jeunesse
quoi d'avoir un petit renouveau pour
pour saint-quentin gospel aw il assez
claire grandveau jeunesse alors là
effectivement la chorale aura 25 ans
l'année prochaine donc al hallaj de
l'âge de ceux ci m'ont donc eric avec
lionel giraud importés ils ont tous
construits au niveau de 7,7 koirala qui
aujourd'hui est composé de quasiment 90
choristes d'accord voilà est donc là
c'est vrai que pour faire un petit peu
le monde ya rebondir sur autre chose
on a fait le pari de choisir un tout
jeune chef de choeur plein de talent
voilà il regrette pas parce qu'on est
ravi de tout ce qui peut nous apporter
au sein de la chorale alors 24 ans mais
une expérience déjà riche vous êtes
passionné de jazz vous avez d'abord
étudier la batterie puis il avait
ensuite découvert la direction
d'ensemble
maintenant le gospel on voit là un début
de carrière bien remplie pourquoi
finalement se diriger vers le gospel
pourquoi se diriger vers le gospel parce
que
parce que déjà c'est une expérience de
direction commune aux traits parce que
jusque là j'essaye d'élaborer un
parcours personnel qui n'est pas enfermé
dans un style musical particulier que ce
soit la musique classique où que ce soit
le jazz
parce que du coup et jazz musique
classique double casquette on imagine
qu'il ya aussi enfin vous allez me
servir de cette double casquette pour
pour cette direction je me sers de cette
double casquette vous en pour la
direction parce que parce que le chant
mine de rien il ya des bases communes
sur des sur la technique vocale alors
moi je ne suis pas du tout prof de chant
ce n'est pas du tout ma formation
supplice directeur musical
mais voilà directeur musical inclut
aussi entre autres sur des pratiques
amateurs d'avoir des notions de
technique vocale pour pouvoir permettre
au chanteur et auquel on doit progresser
dans leur pratique du chant tout en se
faisant évidemment plaisir alors sur
cette année 2018 on est en début d'année
2018 quelle son cas vont être les grands
30 les grands temps forts pardon pour
saint-quentin gospel mais on a quelques
concerts qui sont déjà prévues en mars
un concert les 10 mars à achat ville à
10 et 17 mars aussi à montfort l'amaury
et puis ans mais également ceux
rambouillet et puis sur poissy je crois
bien voilà et donc d'autres concerts qui
sont prévus également en fin d'année est
ce qu'on peut souhaiter à la chorale ben
plein de concerts c'est les boeufs en ce
début d'année qu'est ce qu'on peut lui
souhaiter plein de concerts dès que nous
faire du toujours du plaisir à chanter
ensemble menée par un super chef de
choeur donc oui c'est moi qui seront
peut vous souhaiter au hamois pas grand
chose parce que je suis quand même très
heureux dans ce que je fais au coeur
beaucoup de réussite beaucoup de plaisir
parce qu on est vraiment sur une
dynamique qui est qui est assez
intéressante au niveau du chant et au
niveau de l'ambiance générale
merci à vous deux à michel renard
chargée de communication pour saint
quentin à gospel et à six mois le héros
nouveau chef de choeur de saint quentin
gospel et pour retrouver toutes les
dates des concerts toutes les
informations sur cette chorale
saint-quentinoise vous pouvez vous
rendre sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
avant de refermer ce journal ce matin
c'était la rentrée pour plus de trois
cent cinq mille élèves des yvelines
après deux semaines de vacances de noël
comment les écoliers de la primaire
jules-verne à montigny le bretonneux
ont-ils vécu ce retour au travail
interview collectées au micro de patrick
jacques de dixmude g chez travail
j'ai fait de la grammaire
c'est chez j'ai corrigé des exercices on
sait raconter ce qu'on a fait pendant
les vacances et on a fait les
mathématiques
moi je suis sorti au cinéma je racontais
mes cadeaux après l'agent peut dans la
cour à 10h a fini à 10 heures van natta
monter les vacances avec sa détresse
tu es contente de reprendre l'école ou
alors tu aurais préféré rester en
vacances du mois il est préféré je
préfère rester il faut travailler à
l'épreuve on leur souhaite bon courage
ainsi qu'aux parents qui ont pu aussi
reprendre le travail aujourd'hui c'est
la fin de ce set 8 journal c'est à
revoir en replay sur notre site internet
et notre application mobile tv
soixante dix huit belles soirées
excellente semaine à tous
[Musique]